yeah when i was young it you know it
wasn't
it wasn't there i mean i remember when
butterscotch first hit the scene and
they didn't it just people people were
shocked
you know people they didn't know what to
do i remember
you know people covering their
children's eyes and
you know people just hanging garlic on
their door
and all the people it just because it
had never been you know this is back
when they only had a certain amount of
flavors
in existence you know they had
strawberry
they had vanilla they had uh chocolate
those are easy that's basic
that's your natural three you know and
then somebody come along with a mint
somebody come along with a banana
and you know when then the the flavor
the flavor uh
the palette you know the flavor rainbow
was getting thicker
and then somebody added in uh i don't
even know what they added in at that
point peanut butter bacon
you know um raspberry some [ __ ] said
hey what about raspberry and people said
oh
dang it and things was getting wild and
then i remember
butterscotch hit
and i remember where i was man i was in
second grade and
i was in math class and i didn't know
what was going on
you know they were talking about you
know addition and subtraction and i just
i mean my world was just starting to
damn fall apart
and uh and somebody handed me one of
them
one of them bs's baby just wrapped up in
a beautiful little
cellophane skirt you notice in a little
damn plastic straight jacket just sealed
off at both ends
and i opened that bastard up and i put
it in my mouth and i just
it was like somebody had just i mean it
was butter and scotch you know it just
people didn't know it did you you nobody
done anything like this
you know maybe you'd seen it written on
a toilet wall or something
you know larry loves butter and larry
loves scotch
but you'd never see larry loves butter
scott you wouldn't see
it just it just and then it hit the
scene and it was
you know all the fatties all the thicket
thicks out there wanted that butter and
all the drunken drips out there wanted
that scotch
and you'd see people fist fighting for
them
you know you'd see people just beating
their damn step daddies with a freaking
you know just be you you see somebody
beating somebody else with a damn bike
chain
for a damn werthers you know it was just
it was a different time baby it was a
different time man
god is good brother let's get into it
gang but yeah where were you when it
when a flavor hit do you remember
do you remember where you were when you
first learned about a flavor
because i remember that butterscotch
baby
that thing came across the aisle that
had been
you know probably smuggled into who
knows into the country probably from the
midwest
you know smuggled into the country but
already in the country you know kind of
deal
and it had probably been in six seven
children's hands at school for it hit my
hand
and i opened that beautiful little brown
[ __ ] up
that little mixed mofo
you know and i'd never had anything
brown in my mouth son
you know i was young you know and
and i hit you know and i put that thing
and i just didn't i i
it was just when you first had to take
when you first had a taste of something
new
you didn't know things could could exist
man
and i'll be i mean it's every now and
then still i got to pull my damn car
over if i think too much about a
werther's originals
if i think too much about a you know a
unique type of caramel candy i gotta
pull a damn car
over you know take a break
you know maybe listen to a little jeff
buckley or something i gotta pull the
car over
and relax
i mean you know i miss sometimes i miss
the the innovation
of being young
of being new in the world
because everything you saw was new
you saw somebody you know maybe you saw
two homeless people you know one of them
ripping the other one's tooth out
out by the donut shop doing bootleg
dental
and it yeah but it was beautiful it was
new
you know maybe you see a man hugging
somebody in his family too hard
yeah but you know you hadn't you'd never
seen it like that
it was new
you know you just things were different
you just uh there was i like the novelty
of being youthful and of just of
nouveau of things being exciting there's
something beautiful about that
of somebody hitting you with that with a
new taste
here's a spare rib and you're like what
is this is it you know
i thought it was from the dang bible
when i read it on a menu
i said well damn is it you know is this
the does the church run this place
then my mom say no this this damn ground
patty junior this ain't
the church i have nothing to do with
this joint good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or
watch this one watch this one watch this
one watch this one
ah